lack of Serotonin was thought to be the
cause of depression and then recently
they were like no that's actually not
the case yeah they're like there's no
evidence that serotonin plays a role in
depression but sometimes it's hard to
tell too how many people on this Earth
are getting six hours of sleep
perpetually have to get up under celeb
drive to a job they hate and there's so
many like different factors from a
lifestyle perspective that are so
deleterious to all of the hormone
systems and weren't you on Adderall at
the time too when you were trying yeah
so like I imagine that future sleep up
brutally at the same time it's like a
vicious circle effect like sometimes
you'll take a drug to correct an issue
that was caused by some lack of
foundational principles from a lifestyle
perspective and then using that might
fix something acutely but on the
backhand [__] up the Baseline stuff